[موسيقى]
في حاله اذكرها بالذات هذه السيده عمرها
30 سنه يعني مره ثلاثينيه وام اطفال صغار
ما راى جميله جدا شعرها طويل وجميله ويعني
يعني وحده انوثتها
يوميات العياده وكان عندها سرطان في الثدي
وطبعا الدكتور خبرها الدكتور اللي يعني
كان عيالات الوقت خبرها انه لازم نشيل
صدرك
قالت لا انا انا اموت وصدري موجود ولا
تقصونه يعني ما رضت انها قصه صدرها وقالت
خليلها قلها بتموتين السرطان بيكبر بينتشر
قالت اموت بصدري كامله ما ابي تقصون صدري
ما اقدر اعيش يوم واحد وانا حاسه انه يعني
بدون صغر
وفعلا يعني بخلالي ست شهور او سبع شهور
طبعا رفضت العلاج رفضت العلاج تماما يعني
انتشر الورم للاسف طبعا توفت
[موسيقى]
لعائله طبيه بحته دكتور مؤمن
معروف بالخليج
وهو يعني تربيتنا كانت او تنشئتنا من
الاساس انا واخواني الخمسه كلنا اطباء لكن
كل واحد كان حر في اختيار المجال اللي حاب
يبدع فيها او اللي يحب او يكمل فيه
[موسيقى]
المريضه من تكون مسابق مرض سرطان الثدي ما
اسوي لها استئصال كامل بحيث انه نشيل
الشكل الثدي من عندها لا نشيل الورق
والسرطان والمنطقه الانسجه الثدي ونرمم عن
طريق يعني
دهون من منطقه ثانيه بحيث نحافظ على شكل
الثدي نفس الوقت العمليه المريضه لما تطلع
من عمليه السرطان هي يعني شايلين
في نفس الوقت فما تدخل في الاثر النفسي
انه تشوف نفسها بدون ثدي فتقول لي كلمه
اخذ شاور واسبح واطالع روحي بالمنظره
واشوف صدري موجود
دكتوره وادعي لك اقول يعني الله يوفق
هالدكتوره ويرزقها لان
اعطيتيني شيء
انا عشت مرحله انه ما كان عندي صدر فكنت
سيئه سيئه سيئه ونفسيا حيل متضايقه
وتعبانه
لما عيشتيني هالاحساس مره ثانيه ورديتي لي
جزء يعني اشكرك من كل قلبي فهذه هذه يعني
الاشياء اللي دائما تخلي الواحد الطريف
يواصل لما يشوف رده الفعل من الناس لما
يشوف
بحبهم واهتمامهم ودعواتهم هذا الشيء هو
الدافع الاسمى
عملي كجراحه يخلي تقبل
الرجل او الزوج
اوقات العمل وتغيب المستمر عن البيت
يعني صعب فانا احترم يعني قرارات ازواجي
بالانفصال وهذا شيء يعني وارد
[موسيقى]
انت كامراه مثل الذكر في الطموح واحد في
الاهداف في مساعده الناس مثل ما الرجل
الجراح يستخدم فئه معينه من الناس ايضا
المراه الجراحه تخدم فئه معينه من الناس
ويمكن اكثر
[موسيقى]